i read one science fiction story where
the bad guy
gets thrown into a black hole and he
screams
in fact he screams forever
i'm dr michio kaku professor of
theoretical physics and
best-selling author of the god equation
and i'm here today to answer your
questions on twitter
this is physics support
[Music]
cal is not a cow ask y'all
why do atoms want to bond so much
why don't they just stay single you
aren't missing
anything atoms want to bond together
that's why we have molecules that's why
we have people
dna our universe is based on atoms which
like to bond with each other the
electron vibrates
back and forth binding them together and
that's why we have molecules
that's why we have you you are a
consequence of the fact
that electrons are shared between
different atoms
using the laws of the quantum theory
deborah morozak
asked the question what's your favorite
law of physics
mine is momentum conservation well my
favorite law of physics is the
equivalence of matter
and energy einstein's equation e equals
m c squared this is why the sun shines
it's why the stars twinkle it's what
lights up the universe
we like to think that matter and energy
are totally different things
how can a rock turn into energy however
if that rock is
uranium and that energy is the fireball
of a nuclear bomb you realize that
matter
and energy are two sides of the same
coin
matter energy is one unit and they can
flip into each other under certain
circumstances
like in the heart of a star sean harris
at infosec hotspot asks does anyone know
of people like
michio kaku that can explain
string theory like he does for people
like me
and i'm not a genius well i am michio
kaku
and i'd be glad to answer that question
first of all most textbooks say
that an electron is a dot particles
that we see in our atom smashers are
dots but if i had a super microscope
i can see that that dot is actually a
rubber band
from a distance this rubber band looks
like a dot
close up you see that it's a vibrating
string
now this rubber band can vibrate in many
different modes
each mode can be called a particle so
for example
this might be an electron but if you
twirl it in a different way
it becomes a quark and if you twirl it
this way
you have to give it a different name we
call it a neutrino
now how many ways can one string vibrate
the answer is obvious an infinite number
of vibrations
on the same string and so we think that
all the subatomic particles of the
universe
the quarks the neutrinos the mesons
the protons and neutrons there's a
galaxy of these particles they're
nothing but musical notes on a tiny
rubber band
a rubber band so small that it looks
like a dot
so what is physics that we had to
struggle with in high school
physics is the harmonies the harmonies
of vibrating strings
physics tells us how these vibrations
move
what is chemistry chemistry is when
these strings
bump into each other and form molecules
alex add kuransk skong
asked what is a quark what is omg
yeah it's a oh my god we think that
inside the proton
there are three quarks subatomic
particles that make up the protons and
neutrons
which in turn make up our universe
here's a question from
rick at sojourner99
we live in four dimensions but can see
three
how many dimensions are there einstein
says we live in a
four dimensional world we can go forward
backward
left right up down and the fourth
dimension
is time but now we're beyond einstein
and we have to go beyond four dimensions
to perhaps let's say
10 11 dimensions but where are these
other dimensions
we think they have curled up they're so
small that you cannot enter them
but perhaps we can feel their effects
and where is this other dimension
it is off the plane of your universe
perhaps a parallel universe hovering
right above your universe
in another dimension that we cannot see
or touch but perhaps
there's a gateway connecting them that
gateway
is the wormhole it was einstein himself
in 1935 who
introduced the concept of a wormhole a
gateway
between higher dimensional universes
well the next question
comes from jay mozak who asked the
quantum universe
was einstein wrong about his theory of
relativity
yes and no there's a famous quote where
einstein said
the more successful the quantum theory
gets
the sillier it looks he thought that
atomic physics
that is quantum mechanics was incomplete
when the nobel prize was given to people
like heisenberg
he said yes give them the nobel prize
they're on to something and so weinstein
had
reservations about the quantum theory as
the final theory
he thought there had to be a higher
theory a theory even beyond the quantum
theory
so einstein was not totally incorrect
ob would shaina lang ask what
is the god equation well einstein spent
the last
30 years of his life chasing after
the god equation an equation perhaps no
more than
one inch long that would allow us to
quote
read the mind of god a theory that would
unite the two branches of physics
on one hand we have the theory of the
big general relativity
black holes big bangs and the theory of
the small
quantum theory atomic physics how can
you
unite these two into one theory at the
present time
these two theories hate each other
they're based on different mathematics
different principles different concepts
and yet we believe in our heart of
hearts
there has to be a master theory out
there the holy grail
of physics and that we think is the god
equation
the leading and only candidate for that
is
string theory and by the way if you ever
find the god equation
tell me first we'll split the nobel
prize money together
you and me here's a question from
princeton university press
and that is who is your favorite
physicist
46.2 percent said that einstein
was their favorite physicist 53.8
percent
thought that richard feynman was their
favorite physicist
my favorite physicist is isaac newton
he asked the question for the ages if an
apple falls
does the moon also fall and he realized
that he didn't have the mathematics to
calculate a falling moon
so what did he do he invented his own
mathematics
called calculus and the theory was one
of the greatest theories of all time
newton's law of gravity and so during
the black plague of 1666 one of the
greatest
minds in history went from superstition
and thrust us into the age of mechanics
the industrial revolution he changed
world history
you can't beat that einstein is way up
there so is richard feynman but isaac
newton
tops them all the next question comes
from hassan babanji
who asks can light bend around corners
if yes or no give one reason yes
light can bend around corners in fact
that's why we have glass
inside your glasses when light goes into
glass it slows down slightly
because it slows down it deviates from a
straight line and that's why we have
your glasses
telescopes microscopes because glass
bends light also gravity can bend light
as
einstein showed us and we can actually
see the bending of light as it goes
around
a galaxy then the next question is can
you bend light completely around an
object so the object becomes invisible
and the answer is yes it's well within
the laws of physics that if you could
govern the atomic structure of glass
then light would bend in a way such that
it would completely go around
an object so anything inside that object
becomes invisible
one day we will build a meta material
out of nanotechnology
that will bend visible light so that
anything
inside that capsule will become
invisible harry potter watch out boxy
fan
2001 asks how do black holes distort
time and what the hell does that mean
time does not beat
uniformly throughout the universe clocks
on the moon
beat a little bit faster than clocks on
the planet earth
on jupiter clock speed slower than
on the planet earth the heavier the
planet
the slower time beats this means that on
a star
like the sun time beats even slower
and the ultimate star of course is the
black hole the remnants of a dying star
we think that at the very center of the
black hole
time stops what does that mean if you
were to fall into a black hole
from your point of view it would take
perhaps a few minutes let's say to fall
through a black hole depending upon
where you started from
your watch says that you went right
through to the center of the black hole
but from outside somebody with a
telescope
looking at you from outer space
would see you frozen in time slowly
going
into the black hole because time beats
at a different rate
from the outside and the inside get your
head around this
time can beat at different rates at
different points
in the universe she'll be asked like
how are black holes and infinite density
even
possible like how does something get so
dense that it collapses
on itself i wanna know we know that if i
take a gigantic star
or galaxy and compress it its gravity is
so
great that nothing known to science can
escape
the clutches of gravity so light itself
is
trapped by the black hole and according
to textbooks
it collapses to a point of infinite
density
let's be real about this there's no such
thing as infinite density
we just say that in textbooks because we
don't know what happens
when a star collapses into a tiny dot
infinite density is a shorthand of
saying
i don't know we really don't know what
happens at the very
center of a black hole if you do the
mathematics very carefully
you realize that the black hole is
spinning and
spinning stars collapse to a ring
they don't collapse to a dot at all and
if you fall through the ring the
mathematics says that you fall not just
to the ring
but you fall to the other side to a
parallel universe
that is on the other side of a black
hole there's a white hole
everything that falls in gets blown off
the other end
the village celeb at the village salem
here's a question for physics people
only
i was sitting in the back seat of a bus
which was going at 120 kilometers per
hour
a fly rose from my shoulder and flew
right up front
and landed on the drivers so does it
mean the fly was going
faster than the bus let's let newton
answer this question and that is
velocities can add
if you are a bystander looking at the
bus and the fly from outside
you would say yes the velocity of the
fly
is the velocity of the bus plus the
velocity
of the fly inside the bus velocities
can add now of course if you're inside
the bus
the fly seems to go at a very slow rate
if the bus
is really a rocket ship traveling near
the speed of light
and a fly flies inside the rocket ship
apparently breaking the light barrier
how's that possible well einstein would
say that you cannot
add velocities in relativity the fly
cannot break the light barrier no matter
how fast that rocket
is moving no matter how fast that fly is
moving
you cannot go faster than the speed of
light newtonian physics
is wrong that means that the two
velocities
have to be adjusted because of the fact
that time inside the rocket
has slowed down now this is amazing
but it works and this has been measured
repeatedly
with our particle accelerators and our
experiments
david h app highwell asked this question
what is dark matter can it be touched is
it dangerous
most of the universe is made out of dark
matter dark matter
surrounds the milky way galaxy if it
wasn't for dark matter
the milky way galaxy would have spun out
of control and the earth would be flung
into outer space
can it be touched well no because it
would filter right through your
fingertips
right through the atoms of your body is
it dangerous
no because it doesn't interact with us
and then here's the big question what
is it there's a nobel prize out there
waiting
for that person who can figure out what
dark matter is he said
hiki tak asks what is the difference
between experimental physics
and theoretical physics experimental
physics engages in
reality it does experiments on things
you can touch and feel
theoretical physics tries to explain
how and why that happens einstein did
not do experiments on light beams he did
not do experiments on
stars and galaxies by looking through a
telescope
einstein work with a pencil and paper
that's called theoretical physics and
the heavy lifting
was done by experimentalists who built
the particle accelerators the telescopes
and the devices that allowed us to probe
into the center of stars and
galaxies jihan h asks the question
for physicists is adding a cape to your
superhero costume
enhance your flying abilities i wish
that there was a magic cape that we can
suddenly put on and soar
like superman it doesn't work that way
birds fly
not because they flap their wings birds
fly because of the shape
of their wings the shape of the wings is
an airfoil
a tear shape for the bird's wing
air flows over the tear and under the
tear
creating a partial vacuum on top of the
wing
that partial vacuum means that air has
to flow
upwards to keep that wing afloat it is
bernoulli's principle
so it's not the cape it's the shape of
the wing
that is the key to flying these are the
questions for
today and remember there's no such thing
as a dumb
question years ago when a young boy was
16 years of
age he asked a dumb question can you
outrace a light beam
that 16 year old boy was albert einstein
and that dumb question opened up the
universe
for physicists and for you and me
thanks for watching physics support